please welcome george
welcome
thank you thank you oh george
george
my
beating heart that loves love i love you
you're such a kind good human being
thank you very much it's so great to be
here and i've always been a fan of yours
and ross
to be here with both of you
awesome i mean
you're just such a good person and you
take such good care of people well
that's what it's all about we got to
take care of each other right and on
georgia rescue we say it takes a village
the community's coming together to help
those who need it the most yeah
a long time ago my dad said just be
yourself and my mom she concurred and i
was like it's easier to be me than to
try to be somebody else that part that
part and you
the way you do things and what you do
you are the perfect person to help with
this design drew over so laura is a
nurse and a mom from bohemia new york
she wrote into us for a little help with
diy take a look at this
hi my name is laura jennifer
i'm 40 years old and i live here in
bohemian new york i've been married to
my husband for about 13 years and we
have two great kids together we moved
into our home about five or six years
ago and like any other homeowner you
have great dreams and aspirations of all
the work you can get done right
so we started off with the bathroom
probably not the best idea one of the
tower racks fell and we tried to speckle
it ourselves i have to say i am a nurse
this is not in my wheelhouse not in my
repertoire at all
it's just such an eyesore true can you
please help me with this drover
oh my god
right
i am so excited and honored that you
asked me and i would do exactly what i'm
doing now which is hand the mic over to
george and you could teach us how to do
this that may not be in her wheelhouse
but it is definitely in my wheelhouse
i'm happy to show you and the audience
at home so that everyone can fix the
holes that they put in their walls okay
i have a hole in my new house like there
was i guess supposed to be a door
stopper and i pushed the door and the
knob went boom like that
so i'm looking at it like what do i do
all right well hey this is the perfect
fix right here one of the big problems
people do a lot of times people put a
patch over it what you want to do is
what we have here is a backer plate and
that actually we've already put them in
both here but what it is is just this
plate right here
you slide it and you roll it up like
this so it rolls you pull off the
adhesive right here and then you slide
it in and then this little part you were
asking me about that pulls it taut
against the inside of the wall so now
right now so you're good now it's it's
already there so you guys are good to go
sort of like this is like a taco yeah
you put this right back put it inside
let it expand and then pull it and the
tabs will make the tape yes
it's like that double-sided tape so it's
really a strong adhesive so it's going
to stick to the inside of the inside of
your wall and that way when you're
putting the compound on here it doesn't
just all fall into the cavity of the
wall between the studs that's what it's
called the cavity i love the word cavity
yeah this this is making a lot of sense
right like my mind would never be able
to do this no you'd be filling the whole
the cavity right you would just feel the
cavity you know what i would do a wall i
would just put a painting right here
yeah just to like cover it that's what i
would that was my moving college okay
sorry i did a lot of this okay so once
you get the folded taco with the
double-sided tape and you secure it in
place aka the backer yep now what now
you put this little ribbon right back in
that little hole there okay and now it
is time to fill the hole oh fun okay so
you if you had small hole you could use
something like this which is nice
because it's got the compound in it you
have your little knife and you have your
sandpaper at the end but since this is a
bigger hole yes you guys have to go
hardcore
you're already on it you really want to
over fill the hole at first you want and
you want to start from the middle and
you work your way out i'm very into how
much this looks like frosting like
or cream cheese or something right
that's what i want to say it looks like
a whipped cream it is it's like all
right yep
and then work your way to the edges oh
so yep okay all right nice
yep good oh god you're doing great thank
you
this is very satisfying i like this yeah
yes yes
and just yeah work it out to each edge
so you got it and you just want to
overfill it not too much but yes perfect
drew you are you can come to george
rescue any time
with me
well thanks a lot jordan no you're not
you're welcome too you're welcome
all right so yeah
good good i feel like
i i feel like well i feel like my hole
is a lot bigger than drew is taking a
lot
great all right so now
okay now yes and you work again like i
said you want to work from the middle of
the hole out towards the edges okay
you are basically done yeah
and now i mean they're going to go
a couple spots but i was going to say
once it's all in see that's what
happened
okay good good now we let it dry
and we don't want to overwork the hole
[Music]
all right is that good george just like
can i uh that's that's pretty good
yeah no that's here
just yes no now it's good now it's good
can i do i stop you just stop now okay
i'm stopping i'm stopping don't worry
about like you know the little
improvements because it's gonna dry and
then you can
then we're gonna stand okay
[Music]